April 21st 1967 the tanks rolled into
Athens a right-wing military junta took
over power the head of the new
government was here his papadopoulos
parliament was stripped of power the
Greek king went into exile what followed
was a seven-year dictatorship
characterized by tyranny torture and
censorship Niko's sylvanas fled Athens
for Germany and because in the 1960s
Greece was not a member of the EU he
applied for political asylum he moved to
Cologne and began to work for Dorcha
villas radio program he don't serve
every hit the deutsche welle
successfully kept the people of Greece
informed starting in nineteen sixty-nine
for one full hour per day up until then
the programme was broadcast in the
afternoon but many people were at work
and not able to tune in the former
executive producer Costas nikolaou
insisted on changing the broadcast time
to the evening it ran every night at 940
p.m. all the way through till nineteen
seventy-four Seattle said you do to
Valentina Vemma sexual history and the
hunter was powerless to act against
radio airwaves opposition journalists
such as nikos savara reported from
Athens they interviewed the people the
junta censored left politicians artists
critics of the regime those who are not
allowed to speak their mind publicly in
Athens almost every day the local
pro-government media tried to Paula mais
their audience against door chabela this
made us even more popular the hostility
of the Greek Colonels became free
publicity for us o menos donde como se
acabo bond and any people who could not
flee the country under the dictatorship
were starved for information they met up
to secretly listen to the news might
have to completely what about a sudden
something I knew was on offer yeah the
word got around quickly in our click to
tell the truth the broadcast was
forbidden
Reese but we listened anyway and over
time our clique got bigger the evening
news show gave us a reason to meet every
day hope and a lifeline to the world are
of fundamental importance to those who
are suppressed under tyranny thousands
of journalists such as Nicholasville
ailis were jailed he was put in a high
security track on Corfu today foo
leila's continues his work as a
journalist producing a left-wing
newspaper back then he kept up his
connection to the free world by
listening to deutsche welle st feel like
ye y política too many then we were
political prisoners and secretly owned
radios every night we would hide them in
a different place the person who had the
radio had to listen to all foreign
programs from DW to the BBC and the next
morning he or she had to summarize the
news for the other prisoners we belong
to all sorts of resistance organisations
the hooter held on to power for seven
years but the pressure on the government
gained strength and the resistance
followed the events on the radio finally
the regime shattered and Greece returned
to democracy and freedom of the press